feel pays this poor dude 40 bucks oh
hold on
i said how much for a full body goes 40
for an hour bro 44 an hour
right it's 44 hours this is how the guy
finishes he stands in front of you right
and he will backflip and [ __ ] land in
the middle of your back yeah
no it does unbelievable yeah it's forty
dollars
tip 40. that's sex trafficking
[Music]
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
culture corners looking like a van's
convention look at you
i just realized that did both you ride
your skateboards here
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love vans man those are fire girl i
like your socks yeah
thank you appreciate you coming in oh
yeah thank you for having me
yeah well why are you talking like that
i feel like what
huh she just said she's like what like
you're talking like you're like
you're you don't collect uh you're not
collecting your lips while you're
talking wait i just got them done so i'm
getting used to that
did it hurt yeah it hurts it hurts real
bad i've see i've seen a girl get it
done several times and it looks
so [ __ ] painful [ __ ] awful and uh
is this the first time you've done it
third
yeah because that's the thing got them
done tell it what you're talking about
either
injections botox like testosterone yeah
like testosterone
testosterone no it's not stopping
it's lip filling they use a little
needle and some girls it doesn't stay
everyone thinks they're like kylie
jenner but they look more like [ __ ]
keanu reeves so they they try to get it
done all the time yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you know no i'm addicted i just know man
you're addicted yeah is that
have you done anything else no that's it
yeah but that that
dude i'm telling you nick bring up a
video
it looks like i'm serious bro so it
looks like it looks like she gave a blow
job to a really hot piece of pizza
and i don't mean that in any and i'm not
assuming you get [ __ ] honestly
is dressed like the rock from
all that famous halloween costume um
looks like every character
from fresh prince of bel-air
dressed like the r.i.p phil bro
no but it looks like an extra straight
out of compton
yeah take us back to those floaties at
least if you ever were on a if you were
on a ship they went down you could just
like
they're heavy no they're heavy are they
these would sink me yeah for sure
yeah and this is you you said your third
time doing it when was the last time you
did it last week
so they're brand new oh which is why it
looks like a
oh
the bottom you're good yeah
dude i got my bottom lip from atlanta
there you go baby
bottom lip is liquid i.v
this thing's had some packets um
so this is actually ideal timing because
uh for this episode we're gonna bring
back a roast my host uh gabby's got some
uh some of the best comments uh burning
uh
all of us in the room from youtube some
instagrams
uh some some mean tweet-esque thing the
good ones the funny ones the funniest
[Laughter]
yeah you said it looks like she does
blow jobs at quiznos yeah yeah
[ __ ] no first of all he said pizza not
quiznos yeah
i said pizza's mine cause they they dish
out hot subs i said
i didn't know
no i said that it looked like
she she's been
she her lips don't seem very activated
yeah they are they are now were they
were they bruising before this a little
bit
they're a little bruising it looks bad
when you get it so can you eat or do you
just
like kind of throw stuff over yourself i
can eat i can just
i can eat yeah no i can eat through the
wire
were your lips real thin before they
were fine
they were fine the woman who injected
them was like these were thin and i was
like i get it
i get it that's why i'm here
yeah i feel like those are the lips like
that they remind you if you're going on
a swimming field trip to bring the
summer camp with you in the morning
you know yeah yeah yeah thank you yeah
but no you look you look lovely and uh
let's find out more about our new uh
guest in the culture corner
what's up girl yeah we know we know
should be
should i roast them no no we'll go to
that app let people get to know your
comic your local comic in l.a yeah
but you're from san diego san diego wins
ocean side and you've been in la how
long ten years
oh wow you've been with kami ten years
no i started doing comedy five
four and a half five years ago you
originally came to la for what four
to get out of san diego what happened in
san diego [ __ ] it sucks
okay really san diego sucks dude san
diego from all the movies
san diego from all over the world i mean
it's fine but if there's nothing i bet
you want to go back now though because
later today yeah
i'm gonna show them around they haven't
seen it yet they haven't haven't no they
haven't
they don't know they don't know have
your parents seen your new lips
they [ __ ] hate them yeah you hate
them yo hate them
do you have brothers and sisters i have
two older brothers are they oh older
brothers oh careful brendan will try to
[ __ ] those [ __ ]
oh it doesn't matter
well i'm sure your older bros aren't
pleased with your big lips i don't know
i'm not sucking their dick so it doesn't
matter yeah but you're their little sish
you know
yeah now what do you think your parents
don't like about it
they they're like why do you have to get
they hate tattoo they hate my tattoos
they hate my lips
like why are you doing this to yourself
so you're on your parents [ __ ] list
a little bit yeah because you're tatted
up tatted it up lipstick
yeah but who comments more about about
the lips about it your dad or mom you
think
probably my mom oh wow yeah she's uh
yeah she's not into it
are they happy that you're a comic
though he means he's your mom hot that's
what he's trying to ask
his and are they happy that i'm a comic
yeah sometimes
sometimes they'll watch my [ __ ] now like
do you really have to talk like this and
i'm like
oh my god yeah don't come don't come
don't watch
yeah yeah i haven't come in four days
actually
oh good for you makes sense i'm doing
pretty good you're a little prickly that
makes sense
a little quickly doing pretty good man
who's funnier out of you and chappelle
you think is he really
chappelle yeah okay oh you guys know
each other yeah
oh just from there yeah yeah like what
three years now
maybe four years maybe you've only been
in la three years right yeah yeah but i
met her beforehand yeah before i moved
out here oh no oh what happened
just like i met you two before i moved
out here i never met you before yeah i
did
we did how different i met you in 2016
at tempe improv
and hannibal hannibal burst came through
as well yep
i remember that was a good time and then
i uh what the [ __ ] i mean a while ago
i
you guys met in one of the stables at a
golden corral
and then how do you guys know each other
let me guess a.a i know you live
let me guess theo selling merch at his
a.a meeting
[Laughter]
yeah first of all both of you guys can't
laugh like that
no but even the control rooms dude
he lit up the sponsor because the
lettering was off
good call these sponsors
the tie-dye shirts are short that's how
it works
and they are short yeah and you can mail
those back to brendan actually
guys um so what um
what else are we saying let's read some
mean uh
mean is it mean tweets i mean comments
who picked these
huh who picked these uh uh a buddy of
mine who uh
is a huge fan of the show and wanted to
do a contribute okay
this guy sounds like a hater yeah i
don't know he's like hey here i'll pick
these things though
he he loves the show like yeah yeah he's
a fan a
huge fan of both of you we're gonna find
out who he loves more theo based off
these
or if he's fired or not yeah all right
all right uh theo theo looks like the
guy that pumps your gas
and doesn't even work there moto writer
2024.
okay funny when you read it i would stop
after the thing and then wait a second
and then let us know if you said it
great okay just to accentuate the judge
gotta act like you're burning them
okay yeah harness that anger from
earlier okay yeah yeah yeah he
said something so don't seem bored when
i read it squeeze some of the venom from
your lips
into your body just take a small
i'm sorry i think you look lovely and
i'm just joking nah man i know
you feel like i'm making you digs now
all right i got you girl don't worry
subtle digs is the name also of a black
male somewhere
somewhere in america let's be honest
it's also a rapper subtle dude
yeah subtle digs he's tight white out
too
um so you don't think i'm being mean to
you do you no i don't think you bring me
to me
and honestly i kind of like it so it's
fine um and by kind of i mean really
should i read another one
yeah yeah read away yeah good hold off
on the name you got it
theo looks like the depressed version of
elf on the shelf
that's a really good one that's really
good both of those are good yeah i
thought the first one was good first
one's all right second one's funny
yeah sat on the shelf i like that it
helps if you just stare into the camera
while they read it
about you brendan because then it just
sort of make it land better
you know what i'm saying though like
it'll just help both of us like if i
look in mine when they're reading it
yeah maybe
hit it girl you can do some brexit you
can mix them up yeah you make some of it
we don't have to just roast them we even
got some culture corner i think we do
yeah
yo man dudes losing their hair is a real
prom mr vaughn
yep i guess a lot of people don't have
hair anymore nope how about 60
66 percent of dudes start to lose their
hair by 35
and once it's gone it's too late man so
you got to do something about your hair
while you can do it i'm talking about
for hims.com a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care
sexual wellness for the bros because the
thing is is
you might have hair but you might not
yeah you got to figure out man and
thanks to science baldness it's an
option don't be looking like larry david
these days
look like prince son and we're talking
no snake oil pills
gas station counter supplements we're
talking about the real deal holy field
prescription solutions backed by science
oh yeah i used to take them ones that
would make my
they made my belly button kind of real
sore yeah you don't want that man all
you got to do is answer a few quick
questions and medical professionals will
review and determine
if it's right for you next you know it
shows up right to your crib
yep let me tell them right now our
listeners can get their very first
visit absolutely free go to for
hymns.com
k-a-t-s that's for him f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com slash k-a-t-s
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hems will give you a full
refund prescription products require an
online consultation with a health care
provider who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions apply
see website for full details important
safety information remember
that's for hims.com k-a-t-s
look if you haven't if your body still
has hair growing out of it i mean you're
out of your damn mind dude if you look
like a hairy russian
you're loot you're back in time dog look
at the 80s bro yeah
if your wife uh starts braiding your
back you know
if you have one of your ass cheeks as
cornrowed out
that's on you yeah what you're doing
with your life if your wife has a
mustache listen get the new lawnmower
3.0
trimmer it's waterproof doug shave her
back in the shower
yeah put that broad in the river and
shave her down because what i'm saying
is
the weed whacker also ear and nose hair
trimmer ah you know anybody with
hairy nose hairy ears it ain't cool yeah
it ain't cool looking like a troll
so don't do that man listen manscape got
you covered from your nuts
they got the crop mop ball wipes just
for you got the manscape for your feet
we're talking about the foot duster you
want to smell good we got cologne
get hard stay hard baby get 20 off with
free shipping with code king
sting k-i-n-g-s-t-i-n-g at manscape.com
that's 20 off in free shipping with code
kingston at manscape.com
be sure to join the manscape movement
these products are
no joke son that's manscape.com use code
kingston
okay i like this one um theo looks like
the kid who wrapped his mouth around the
water fountain faucet
guilty as charge for me yeah i i deep
thought the [ __ ] out that faucet as a
kid
yeah man we're water fountain for
christmas but
but he wanted chocolate milk in it now i
want gravy out of that [ __ ]
that's gross
[Laughter]
all right we ready for brandon um yeah
okay brennan looks like a tourist who
travels between genders
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
crossing the state line better put my
tampon in
[Laughter]
brendan looks like he got homesick at
his own sleepovers
[Laughter]
and i'm going to remember just so i
remember right now my favorite one ever
that i read was brennan looks like the
kind of guy
that rides a horse with both legs off to
the same side
that was my favorite one ever this is
one of my all-time
uh faves uh that i sent to theo and
brendan once uh
halcyon tv says brendan looks like the
most powerful protester in portland
[Laughter]
he was rocking the beanie in the flannel
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right how about when
the dude said bran looks like the
type of guy that slaps his own ass at
the games
honestly in episode one or two you
killed it with uh
theo looks like the kid at the arcade
who just stands in the back because he
doesn't have any quarters
[Laughter]
you look like the kid who goes to the
arcade but it's too broke so he watches
everybody else
[Laughter]
oh bro that move was sick uh yeah yeah
back up bro
yeah thank you thank you back the [ __ ]
up bro my parents love me you have no
quarters get the [ __ ] back
that was me bro and when that dude was
done i would go up real quick and try to
touch the controls to see if it was
still working a little hopefully they
still had some lies left
[ __ ] and then just push the little slots
in for the quarters
that was yeah that was just you guys
riffing one or two episode one or two
what else you got gabby anything else in
the tank yeah i do got a couple um
brennan looks like he's social
distancing with his heterosexuality
six feet apart
as soon as we get that vaccine though
we're gonna reconnect
and uh for the culture corner got a
couple
um chappelle looks like he's carrying
the guilt of punching a baby
i could see that actually what i mean
i could see you doing something wasn't
there that story about you where you
like killed your baby sister or
something remember that remember that
about me yeah that's a different guy
they had a different difference
baby unique
baby
that's a nice one though i mean i don't
punch babies but
yeah anything else that's good in there
yeah you know there's a call you oh
don't fire them off
only if it's good okay they're not that
good
but you might get some next week girl i
probably will yeah
she uh she also brought in some tic tacs
for us uh we had gianni kind of educate
us on the world of tick tock you also
brought in some
for us do you want to walk us through
these since then your boy jumped on tick
tock
johnny yeah he got me started on there
uh how do you feel about it
you know i'm just too old for it it's
pretty embarrassing yeah i tried pop
lock in it for the kids
there you go okay i put a thong on said
follow me
but that was for only fans yeah yeah
yeah do they have a better one about me
because i don't like the [ __ ] you're
like the weather
i like the the western was good
hilarious that was a good one yeah i
forgot that that one's pretty good
they're like kind of the other ones are
like kind of nice chappelle is the
whitest black guy i've ever come across
yeah yeah we know that that's a night
that's
thank you i appreciate that um nick
looks like he's gonna start a fire
with some rocks and cook you a mean
steak
again that good seems pretty nice
wow yeah yeah it does that's anything
else
there's no david letterman jokes about
nick on there
not in this one yeah well he's fired uh
but uh
we i there was some absolute gold on
this picture
of oh and they said little brows looks
like simple jack
[Laughter]
looked like the caveman from the geico
commercials yeah the caveman from the
geico commercials
that's what you got there i've actually
been getting that my entire life
uh but let's see there was some fire in
here
there's like cats oh that's on it's on
it might be on cat's profile yeah
word wanna go go to the tic-tacs yeah
let's get into some talks
keep talking it up and talk some tickety
talks oh i thought this guy's so funny
it's gonna be embarrassing if you guys
don't i don't
are we millennials are you a millennial
i think i am are we generations you're
like the last yeah
all right millennials all right you know
last of it yeah
or the beginning are you a millennial
yeah big time
will you count me in oh i love this
i've been awake for a while now
there we go yeah that was the jam i
agree that boy got a little sugar in his
tank but that's the jam
that's rodrigo yeah that's right that's
right
not shocked dude there's nick
what else you got nick this guy is wild
oh look
if it wasn't the person who was making
fun of my beautiful new makeup routine
so you're saying it wasn't you i'm so
sorry for snapping at you just now
psyched [ __ ] as soon as you came
into the room
my wuhan lie detector picked you up as a
snake ass
[ __ ] now watch me practice my gangnam
style [ __ ] bizarre
needs a therapist huh but he like does
all of these tick tocks that look
like he's really unhinged i watch him
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on he's
probably that's probably his way
it's like his help maybe and
betterhelp.com
[Laughter]
is unfucking hinged it is unhinged
chasey fry is the best i think
who's that yeah does that guy have a
huge following yeah like killing it
yeah he has like two million followers
really yeah that's
interesting but there's just there's
something different
about tick tock right it's like
it's like um like what is that dude
gonna do you can't go watch him do
something
yeah that's boring yeah right
some people can maybe but i don't know
what maybe they do q and a's maybe i
don't know
didn't some girl like who got famous on
tick tock just get a netflix special
and it bombed oh wow
yeah i don't remember her this sucks for
her yeah maybe hannah gatsby
[Laughter]
that thing was horrible it was i mean
the woke culture loved it oh they did
yeah
yeah i think if you want men and women
to be the same thing yeah it was a ted
talk
ted talk oh well i'll check it out
tonight
i don't know maybe i might like it oh
she said it went well oh no she was well
because she's the trump girl
no she isn't she the one that did all
the trump bits wait
she did the trump impressions yeah and
then they gave her a special that's her
yeah so she would always make fun of
trump mm-hmm i never got it she got it
yeah it never caught on for me because
she all she did was
reap like she would be a voiceover for
trump and she would just
like mimic his lipstick over it and
people like this is fantastic i was like
what that's the weird thing about that
cuts clips of trump's speech and then
she would lip them and then it would
like go super viral
and then netflix gave her special good
for her for getting a special day yeah
make that money yeah good for you it's
just so [ __ ] crazy though that that
like that's how people can get famous it
was just that was the thing at the time
right like
you know obviously but there's always a
thing here's the one thing though
there's always a thing like put them on
game
that seems like it might be cool if your
watch if you're like thinking oh i want
man i'm bummed she got that you know
mm-hmm but that it that's not
you that's not real there's no longevity
right
that's gonna be that that's it for the
moment yeah yeah
quick yeah it's just not it's not gonna
work especially since trump didn't get
reelected
but yeah that's the longevity i mean
it's just like i remember there was kids
you know i remember being when i was
doing comedy in the beginning and owen
benjamin and nick thune got
they both got like big deals from
myspace i think it was or something else
like
half a million dollars each to make like
videos or something it was like
nobody had ever gotten anything like
that like it was just crazy and so i
remember everybody thinking like
oh man you know like these guys they
they want it they did it you know
and they still both have careers and
stuff but it's not it's just like you
just don't know kind of where
things are going to be at yeah there's
like fads and trends yeah yeah
yeah so where's the longevity right you
know what i mean what was the one that
was like tick tock that oh my god the
little video one
vine vine yeah yeah yeah so many people
got famous off that and a lot of still
famous viners though out there i feel
like
is there i think but some some parlayed
it right like they got real famous on
vine and they start bringing their
talents to instagram
dalia got huge off of vine dog huge
until he got really big on fine then
he kind of that crowd he went to
instagram with it and then and then off
that
off him doing vine he got a [ __ ]
start an eminem video
they saw that video of him rapping and
eminem reach out them
and he's in the m m logic video yeah
just off vine and instagram
instagram doesn't translate to tick tock
though it's weird they're like
so not the same yeah makes me feel old
yeah it's so embarrassing i tried i'm
like on it now and i'm like this is
[ __ ] embarrassing when i see what
goes viral it's like i just don't get it
yeah yeah well one thing about tic toc i
noticed if i watch it
it's more fun to watch stuff on tick
tock than it is on instagram i feel like
it is yeah yeah yeah it is it makes me
just feel good it's easier to navigate
can people leave comments on there yeah
is it different than that
you leave comments but they're always
really like positive tick-tock
commenters are pretty freaking funny
it's like reddit commenters like if
you're on
it's all about what algorithm you get
caught on on your tick tock because like
i'll
one at the end of the night jules is
always on tick tock and she's watching
like to do's
like how to's and like uh uh
do-it-yourself type things and it's like
educational but then like someone else's
tick tock
if you're like a child it'll be all kids
dancing so
if you interact with it it can get
better like you could you could get
be fed only mma [ __ ] or [ __ ]
uh no no you would kill it i announced
it that i was going to a couple weeks
ago and i just never did i missed the
boat
on this show but you would kill it
uh-huh you killed it thanks
you guys he's got something about him
you know that's tick-tock-ish
i think he's where am i tripping he was
busy making the studio
yeah this came from the uh
facebook group um we've got a couple
couple submissions from it uh someone
was like king it or sting it
uh extreme thick boy bike club oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no
[Music]
i said music because the guy dies at the
end
they played this at his funeral yeah
yeah is your uh
biking from san fran still happening uh
yeah get on your bike yeah i'm going san
fran to la though
i got word my guys are specialized like
you don't want to ride
up to san fran because the i guess the
winds they're like it's impo
it's a nightmare because the the wind's
from the pacific so you gotta go down
so yeah all right and i'm doing it with
you do you even have a bike dog
i can get a bike i got a diamondback you
know what i mean they still make
diamondbacks
huffies get those uh you know no put
some uh jean shorts on rollerblade your
ass down though
i'm not gonna [ __ ] rollerblade you
could roll you look like a roller i
could rollerblade but i'm not a
rollerblader
i'd escape yourself what do you do for
athleticism these days gabby nothing
okay
[Laughter]
were you uh popular in high school no no
not at all
what what was your vibe in high school
um no
i get a little bit of gotham no i was
like surfer girl
oh very sorry for girl surfer yeah but i
was like i was always like made fun of i
was never really because you weren't
good at surfing or were you a good
swimmer or what that was good swimmer
yeah yeah yeah
i was like that's good questions brendan
i'm trying i'm trying to get the vibe of
you in high school so you weren't
popular why dude
she's an adult now why are you trying to
we've never been clearly where you guys
met that i've never seen you in a you've
never
[Laughter]
theo starts every a meeting with a hot
15.
let's go material night every thursday
get his merch out the back
that's my time get your hitter
two for 20 cash only i always try and
get laughs when i share and it's a
[ __ ] it's so bad do you do that
i don't do that uh sometimes i maybe do
but it's hard to get out of that mindset
it's really hard i have i know people
that are in his meetings say
feels [ __ ] hilarious oh really no
they're not supposed to tell about that
i know that's just alcoholics yeah yeah
that's alcohol
but uh you go is it weird if i ask why
you go to a meetings
um well you can assume why i just
have a drinking problem yeah yeah did
you really have a drinking problem yeah
you know it started after i got my thank
you i got
after i got my second dui last year i
was like oh you realize you had a
problem
damn girl two two duis you get a third
get
slammed yeah the the first one i got
almost 10 years ago so it was like
almost off my record
that's not bad yeah it's not that bad of
an average of one every 10 years
how about how about drinking are we
talking are you denzel from [ __ ]
flight or what are we talking about
if he's a factor 50 where where are you
at you know it wasn't like
it took me a while to realize like it
was actually bad because i wasn't like a
cl i wasn't like the [ __ ] wake up and
drink vodka you're functioning yeah yeah
yeah but i would just
drive a lot when i would get wasted and
that's where i was
that's a problem that's not good
especially there's uber what did you
like about that when you think about
that what did you like about
is there something you liked about being
in the vehicle like about drives or
something like that i like being in
control
like every time i want to leave i was
like i'm [ __ ] driving people would be
like you're wasted and i'd be like
i'm good at driving though dude get up
no one take your keys get on a bird girl
get on a bird
it was really [ __ ] it was really
stupid it was what was your drink of
choice
beer yeah huh what kind of beer we
talked about bands right there
we're talking about a mickey's what you
what ipas i love ipas
the hipster beer yeah your mouth is
watering right now your mouth ain't
watering
yeah bearings you can't water yeah they
can't you really can't these are some
stuff yeah yeah i'll probably be in your
meetings about a year from now
yeah there's some alcoholics at home
that are pissed that she was
addicted to beer you know yeah but i was
only one beer some guy was like i was
she like
i drank everything but if i had to
choose i would say beer and tequila some
guy's like i was
uh i was injecting heroin directly under
my arms
yellow beer this [ __ ] can't handle an
ipad
that didn't it didn't make me question
it a lot though cause i was like you go
to a.a and you hear all these [ __ ]
stories and i was like i'm like i don't
what does it like it makes you feel good
right somebody's like i used to take one
of my eyes out and uh
yeah dude i i used to have a blind yeah
i had my wife's cocaine behind
dude i had a buddy in college and at the
time it's just you know you drink on the
weekends but he's drinking monday
through sunday yeah and then he was he
couldn't get drunk enough
from just consuming it through his mouth
so he started taking uh enemas and put
him up his ass whiskey called boof and
they call it
with the intent to get high not to be
confused with key string which is
sticking
up something up your butt with the
attempt to conceal okay yes different
also known as a mule in the cartels but
also
uh he was so he would he would soak the
enemas in whiskey
put up his booty and then he would also
sniff whiskey
dude i had a kid this kid and he started
working for the cartel he's on the run
now
when i was growing up his name was cater
right like after the
service you know sure yeah and uh they
he got stopped by the cops one time he
was with a uh another guy that we grew
up with and
he had a bunch of weed he's trying to
put it up his butt
and did it work oh it's pretty dry i
mean yeah i didn't know it was horrible
yeah sounds like a bad idea so he got
pulled over and then he was like hold on
hold on hold on
put his pants down put the seat back
asked his buddy to help him
he's like dude get it in here it was
trying to put and it was like
a lot of it was like shake and stuff
it's just oh horrible idea so the cops
busted him just like that like it was
just a bunch of weed hanging out of his
butt
yeah we got you now but there's also
been some people with like cocaine
they put them in uh you know bags and
[ __ ] and then when the cops go to get
them they put them up their ass or they
swallow them
and then those [ __ ] bags burst and
then they die
yeah everybody knows that though yeah
that happened to a rapper
yeah oh that did happen a rapper uh
what's his name he got a private jet and
the cops were there so he swallowed all
of it oh juice world
uh [ __ ] died yeah oh that's what i'm
gonna do this world yeah
damn no [ __ ] yeah like that he was on a
private jet the cops were like when he
landed
the pilot how about this this [ __ ] ass
pilot the snitch
was like they're doing drugs on the
plane when i land be there so when they
landed there's all these cops so he's
like oh [ __ ]
and swallowed the bags within the bags
[Music]
no shout the juice world damn yeah he
was so young too wasn't he yeah he was a
young guy
yeah this is my favorite [ __ ] scene
ever this is what it
reminded me of when she said she was
addicted to ipas
this is great to die she's here today
because i'm addicted
to marijuana you went here for some
marijuana
marijuana man this is some
[ __ ] marijuana is not a drug
i used to suck dick for coke i didn't
know bob said he was enough yeah
well that's an addiction similar
yeah yeah it is it is addicted to ipas i
just ipa
how many how are we talking the day you
take down no i mean like
i would drink more it doesn't sound like
she has a problem yeah but you think
she's in the zac
brown band or something i can cut her
some slack
man you think she's waking up and just
drinking
blue moons until she can't see out of
the window
no she wouldn't have some and then drive
home do you guys not
understand a story she told us that
never sounds like a problem sounds like
a good time
well it's just like hey but you gotta so
what happened so she'd have a few
shock tops and jump on the birds like
the end of the world man i know
she might not be an alcoholic forever
she's in there right now oh
[ __ ] i listen i don't have a tail on the
dog
you don't give off that vibe alcoholic
no uh well i do
you don't [ __ ] wild turkey or
anything like that that's mushroom i
mean i would drink all of it but if i
had a choice brothers always want to
have a meat you know
no matter what it is
hey man you gotta have wild turkey on
the bone
you know [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
well proud of you for beating it yeah
thank you thank you
well i mean beating it we'll see can you
guys meet during coven
no some of them but like mostly zoom
meetings
yeah no driving you can meet in covid
right yeah i just can't believe you guys
outed this girl about her
hey
because i clearly am a detective
how did you know though because i didn't
tell you because i know
i i know the vibe you know like and theo
just brings a new buddy around every
other week that he made
no i i i'm fine talking about it i don't
care there's that and i like you all my
friends are former addicts so yeah
welcome yeah thank you welcome to this
thank you listen a lot of people lock
down these days you can't talk to your
friend
can't see your counselor your therapist
can't see your best friend
so you're going crazy you can't even see
your worst friend you used to be able to
go see your worst friend at least you'd
drive down the street and see
little henry's a little fake ass yeah
you ain't happy anymore so let better
help assess you
with a person in need we talk about you
can start communicating with a real
licensed therapist in under 48 hours get
hard stay hard baby what i'm talking
about is
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in your area
worldwide though dog but i'm just saying
that it might not be
locally available that's why now they
could get on the internet and get it
done what i'm saying is
visit the website and read the
testimonials that are posted daily
visit betterhelp.com reviews and then
visit
betterhelp.com k-a-t-s that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people
taking charge of their mental health
yep better help once you start living
happier right now and we got a special
offer for the king and sting listeners
get ten percent for your first month at
betterhelp.com
cats get woke get hard baby stay special
offer king and sing listeners get 10 off
your first
month at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s get help
look man i'll say this athletic greens
will give you those athletic browns bro
you know what i'm talking about i feel
you daddy
i'll be painting my bowl brown man and
listen the perfect diet doesn't exist
take it from your thick friend over here
one thing if you're looking for one
product that has high
quality nutrients and they fit it all in
one little scoop we're talking about
that
athletic green send me five vitamins for
your thick ass man look man i'll paint
the back of your cousin's van with my
ass bruh
make sure it's make sure it's filled
with vitamins we talk about the
multivitamin that goes the extra mile
we're talking about athletic greens
multivitamin multimineral get athletic
we gave a little bit to a damn guinea
pig we haven't seen him
nope he started running off yeah rumors
on vacation
we're talking about immune support gut
health daily nutritional it's all
you need give me your gut health boy
thank you
what i'm telling you right now athletic
greens is giving our audience
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one doggy
oh on top of it all in one formula
they're giving free liquid vitamin d
supplement with the first purchase for
additional immune support get the
supplement bro yeah so if you're looking
to upgrade your multivitamin take one
nutritional formula that's going to help
you cover your daily
nutritional basis man you need athletic
greens and right now
athletic greens is hooking y'all up go
to athletic athleticgreens.com
yes you'll receive up to a year's supply
of liquid vitamin d for free with your
first purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com k-a-t-s
is the perfect stocking
stuffer liquid d for your mouth let's
see what this guy has to say we got a
king at her sting it
brendan the uh culture corner
first off thank you guys for what you do
thank you for the free content
every week i look forward to it every
week um
i got a king interesting it for you this
week
male nurses first off kang it or sting
it
[ __ ] second question you get
jacked up in a car wreck you prefer a
male nurse
or a female nurse gang gang
buzz buzz oh i'm never mad at some
gaylord
all right big iron no no no that's
that's that's our end
well thanks for submitting that rin
this guy's probably like god damn you
guys are idiots
well i like male nurses doug okay
brandon you got a friend like
female you know what i'm saying i prefer
a soft touch of a female
what about masseuse male or female
do you want to take this one i like male
masseuse man there you go i i can't have
a male masseuse i can't relax
i like a male because i was real gay
let's be honest
or you might like it yeah i think
exactly
you get a good viet or somebody like
that or somebody who's polynesian thigh
and you get them to do it they do good
nah i got a big russian [ __ ] or a big
fat white girl just with her
fat ass elbow in my back i love you oh
you can't handle that block on your back
you can't handle them
they walk on your back oh you got a fat
girl to walk on your back with a big
cushy feet like elephants are serious
i've never had a massage before really
you don't have people touching you hell
no you're like james i keep hitting you
sorry no no
you're shocked isn't it he hadn't been
in a relationship until last year yeah
okay come on now people i don't like
people touching my shoulders get your
massage in palm beach end of the year
dogs
no [ __ ] no you look tight in those i
would not get angry about it yeah
you're right you're right i was going a
little hard that's exactly hard
you need one to relax still gets them
every funnel that was a little tense i
gotta get them all the time man i love
them yeah
jackpot what do you do so maybe it won't
work chappelle yeah a place
in westwood called siri foot spa
s-i-r-i pays this poor dude 40 bucks oh
hold on
i said how much for a full body goes 40
for an hour bro 44 an hour
right it's 44 hours this is how the guy
finishes he stands in front of you right
and he will backflip and [ __ ] land in
the middle of your back yeah
no it does unbelievable yeah it's forty
dollars
i tip 40. that's sex trafficking
that's what that is for help
you don't think it's weird he's always
doing these [ __ ] tricks for you all
the time
he's trying to get funny saying hello
help me he's never said any of that
i thought he was at one point doing like
some type of a braille okay yeah
i'm arm but he isn't how old is he this
man anywhere from probably
19 to you can't tell i respect that you
can't tell
how do you think he is um
that's a hard one 35 thank you
51 yep 51 no not 51.
oh are you 35. i just turned 43 what oh
you just turned 40 congratulations happy
birthday thank you when was your
birthday
no not just but april i feel like that's
close enough to suggest
okay nope
gaby how old do you think cat is um a
new book
28. it's offensive that's 24. uh i'm 25.
25. okay you have you have the maturity
of a 20 yeah
i would say you're 31. what i would say
that you are 26.
hey real quick you know what honestly i
don't know your age but i'm gonna guess
like 20 seconds
before you answer let me backtrack
because i thought millennial was 30 or
older
no what is no i'm a millennial you're a
millennial yeah i'm like at the very
bottom of
millennials so if not 31. i would say
you're 27.
if you guys are all good at 29. damn 29.
huh
shorty growing up how do you think i am
black don't crack
33. but it sells crack if it's your dad
though
sorry that was just a joke
or also known as millennial all right
all right yeah i'm 33.
are you really are you really chappelle
i got it growing up man
i know i'll be 34 january 23rd that's
right growing up we got a serious girl
moved in a new crib damn coming up
i know headlining his own dates and [ __ ]
yeah we just had to move in and talk
y'all did it what is that what is the
movement like
let's move in again who who brought it
up her you her
her oh yeah do you have a man
um yeah oh
you hesitated it's new or you guys are
on the kind of
it's new okay there you go what kind of
guy is he like is he
white guy yeah okay wow you've only been
with white guys old-fashioned no
fashion old-fashioned well if you've
seen all the commercials everybody on
commercials now is mixed-race couples
you notice that
yeah every commercial every commercial
every [ __ ] commercial yeah it's your
vision beige power baby that's true
commercial and espn you
where'd you guys meet at is he a comic
no no no god no no uh mutual friends
hell yeah and if you ever dated outside
of your race that means black
yeah and mexican then mexico
wow i didn't usually go for it but you
don't think she's dated a mexican before
get the [ __ ] out of here
just settled on a wife you settled on
yeah let her live her life did you ask
her if she
got with any black dogs yeah have you
been with anybody
in the circle of trust i was with a
black woman yes you've been with a black
woman i think so man
i think so have you ever been with the
asian through
i don't see you and asians a korean lady
i think
this was years ago in boise idaho
and she had like a uh not a lot of
asians out there i was just there last
weekend
yeah really i didn't see one different
race than than white
wow there's some mexican guys there's
some mexicans in the crowd
yeah there's some mexicans this lady she
was uh
i don't know what you i don't know what
her name was i don't know would you meet
her at a show
maybe another show i remember are you
trying to get a massage no
i met her in person i met her in person
ooh
okay wow a korean and a black wow nick
nick
have you ever been with a black girl
mm-hmm
i'm like chappelle's late bloomer with
like serious relationships jules is my
first
first like real girlfriend i'm proud of
you guys and me and nick are killing it
[ __ ]
everybody they're talking about 20 20.
it's crazy i'm sad
man nick are killing it that's nine
months of my life yeah look at that
come on love is tight love it
now back to the black girl though nick
that korean girl was point three percent
of the boise population
wow diamond in i should have broke out
the
metal detector while i was there diamond
in the ramen
what's up
hell yeah almost good
really
but i said diamond rough and then i
thought of diamond the ramen is too late
i don't know i think you did pretty i
think you did it pretty good man you
know actually
it wasn't that bad thanks you liked it i
liked thank you yeah but he works for
you
i work for you too and i laugh at your
stuff that's a good point yeah thank you
bro yeah see
here's this guy so we don't know what's
going on yeah you don't know what's true
i feel like i feel like nick's a good
indicator though that's funny that could
be true
yeah chen is uh no she's alive captains
are pretty good yeah she is that doesn't
[ __ ] that's true yeah
she gives her 100. what's what's this
young man saying with a horse he's next
to a horse
that's a mini horse i don't know who
it's mr hands what's up gang pearson
from orange county i'm here with willow
we just want to know keeping little
peach fuzz hitters like this
in the zoo we're letting them out
gang gang fuzz fuzz ooh i love that nose
here's the thing dog you can't let those
things out they'll [ __ ] die
because those mini horses aren't made
for the wild yeah
they breed them i think it's like a mini
horse is a donkey and a horse
because donkeys can't or it's a mule
can't procreate yeah
oh yeah yeah i've seen a donkey [ __ ] up
a hyena
like have sex with it it's not were you
in tijuana no like
like beat the [ __ ] out of it oh yeah
donkey's like beat up hyenas and [ __ ]
where is
[Laughter]
his dad just passed away someone just
passed away i meant
i think it might be the second video oh
his brother passed away look at this
that's the way
his brother passed away and his mother
is that a donkey that is
[Laughter]
how fast
[Laughter]
dude
yeah all animals get pulled from the
neck though because i wouldn't tighten
my body up if the donkey's pulling me
around
i know right i'd go limp too yeah
i would tighten up you would yeah okay
right up yeah have you ever been
attacked by a man no
oh damn no i wouldn't know you ever been
attacked by anything
any sharks or anything surfing all the
time
no we
hooked up with black guys he's like come
on brendan have you ever been hit by a
dude
and that's the safe zone i just wanted
to i like good stories here's a guy over
here
hey y'all it's ace again i got another
one for you
it's real simple debate club
king kong or jaws
that's a great gang buzz buzz
well there's a lot of factors that go
are they fighting in the ocean what do
you think chin take us into some of this
i know you guys fishing is big in
y'all's industry what did you got
and invented king kong yeah and invented
king kong so take us
yeah why don't you and cat give us some
just some insight into the invented
godzilla
yeah we did godzilla yeah oh king kong
is american dog oh yeah
yeah he went in new york y'all some
[ __ ] yeah king kong's as american as
it gets
godzilla's korean jokes i've talked to
king kong he
got an issue with him okay
but there's always been an issue between
black and asian i feel like
i don't know what it is black and yellow
crime is that special korean and blacks
we don't [ __ ] with each other for the
longest time in the 90s in l.a
we're so far apart from each other i
know no no we live in the same area
south central
oh you're talking about the la rights i
was talking about africa and asia oh
yeah but you're talking about the l.a
riots yeah yeah they own liquor stores
yeah the liquor stores yeah what
happened what was their beef was it any
two people started it do you guys feel
like
the [ __ ] black people [ __ ] running
a buck it was black people trying to rob
but there's one incident the craziest
incident that started to kick it off was
this little black girl trying to steal
orange juice and then the lady got this
killing her and the lady killed her she
shot her because the girl was hitting
her in the head with the orange juice
i think it was the oranges with herself
like that yeah and then the
older korean lady she grabbed the gun
and shot her and that is this on top
jesus christ no brandon i don't know
wow we just got real dark in here yeah
yeah yeah
you know what it does get educational i
don't even it does yeah that's why i
thought it was on there
hey but is uh also what's weird is when
you see a group of koreans like american
koreans that are kind of from
the hood quote by the holland rays
yeah yeah uh when they when they they
they feel like they have the right to
use the n-word have you ever heard
koreans use the n-word i've heard it
i've heard asians
yeah in general yeah they use it a lot
of asians
like his whole album like he's just
saying it the whole time a lot of
cambodians from long beach also yeah
really
that's the big one wow
that's what they call them yeah that's
what they call them yeah i didn't know
that
everybody has a nickname yeah yeah okay
what was the first limbs muslims
and i made that one up that's a good one
thank you very much
[Laughter]
oh dude if you want the rs's man i got
him bro the ingram's from ohio here the
family issue now what was that last guy
we never even answered jaws or godzilla
you thought it was asian uh it depends
where it goes down if it's in the water
obviously jaws would [ __ ] them up
if it's on land king kong would win king
kong's too big though yeah but how tall
is king kong he could like stand up
let's do giant
clowns it's obviously going to take
place on the shore
guys right they're not going to be able
to fight otherwise king kong
what about the movie oh the movie which
movie's better
yeah the king kong with jack black's
pretty good thing and the new king kong
with uh samuel l jackson's really good
too oh kong island
yeah kong island's dope samuel jackson
sober do you know that
no he is 25 years old no [ __ ] he's
awesome you tell when you're watching
him i just realized that yesterday yeah
he he has he has a pretty great story
you know he won't say no to any role or
any part that's why i see him in the
gillian [ __ ] things if his agents
bring to him he says yes to everything
more you know uh what else you got nick
the ingram all right guys i gotta king
it or sting it for you
uh letting your kids watch rick and
morty brendan
or letting your kids listen to eminem
edited
of course somebody
please help me good night
i think my dad's going crazy oh
thanks guys we love you bye oh super
cute listen
beautifully my son watched every season
every episode of rick and morty he's
obsessed with pickle rick so i got
pickle rick toys
and then from there season four big
mouth just dropped so we started
watching big mouth
don't watch that with your kid it is so
[ __ ] vulgar
oh my god oh god we're just like don't
watch that that show looked gross
no no it's funny big mouth
fantastic hey look gross i was the first
episode of team grove no nick crawl
killed it with me
yeah i think it's so funny but don't
watch it with your kid i [ __ ] up don't
watch it with your kid theo no
i don't have a kid no not that you know
i just threw it out there
i am a kid i won't watch it yeah it's
great though but rick and morty i would
uh drink more you can watch with the kid
it is yeah that really yeah for sure i
was watching it the other night i was
like damn this is
there's so much cussing i'm not worried
about cussing it's weird when people
like i'm not worried about it because i
wasn't sheltered from cussing either
like as long as your kid knows when to
use it when not to yeah
that's when you tell them not to do is
when they start doing it with my son
like you know what i'd say around
adults and in school right he's like
yeah yeah i'm like cool man he's like
now give me a [ __ ] um
uh do you have like age restrictions on
movies and like our movies and stuff i i
watched
everything as a kid i watched everything
too i feel like we're pretty normal nick
yeah
so i don't really constraint my son with
anything i i just let him know
i did [ __ ] up though because he loves
music videos like he's obsessed with
like dosia cat
and [ __ ] all that stuff bts he loves
bts that's his favorite
yeah yep but i [ __ ] up because i went
to go make coffee and the new
weekend video came on have you seen that
no oh it's
the most violent [ __ ] up video i've
seen it starts off with these two models
who just have
just had like nose jobs find his head on
the middle of the road and then they're
obsessed with weekend
so then they have they they hire like a
guy to come over and dance for him they
kill him
cut his head off but we can't head on it
and then have sex with the dead body
jesus
[ __ ] well my son saw that how old is
your son he's he's gonna be five
so he's four
i like him vernon likes to show off hey
how much he knows hey he's gonna be six
in 13 months
no i [ __ ] up though because now he's
terrified of the weekend yeah
he was like oh friday night he can't
even go to bed yeah terrified of the
weekend
damn uh this one's a good one to get us
ready uh and send in your christmas
submissions uh this is cat's boyfriend
isn't it i think my boyfriend's a little
hotter
are we allowed to pull up a side by side
stevie's definitely better looking whoa
dude calm down brother
he's a very good looking man steve's
better looking for this guy
yeah no offense to this man he's also
good looking it's just i have a problem
sounds like you don't like this guy he
probably seems like a nice guy too
we're all sitting here hating on this
guy stevie's bodied the [ __ ] up too
this guy's probably bought it nobody
knows stevie's body has a six-pack
and a big dick dude if he shaved though
they'd look exactly the same no no
gabby who's hotter her boyfriend yeah
yeah wow good friend
what do you think about that man on the
far left though yeah now what about this
hold on what about this uh alcoholic
church
pastor on the left
[Laughter]
can we scroll over to him
what do you think of that man right
there
she almost looks uh trans in that
picture
no he looks like uh he looks like jay
looks like david blaine if he's always
on a bulking phase
yeah okay that's my older brother
great guy good guy all right uh
what did stevie blue have to say though
let's see
brendan theo what's up
derek also known as big dick rick
coming out of columbus ohio
wanted to just say forget them poop
stain
what can brown do for you and then
purple people eaters
fedex when they both go home at night
what do they do
check their mailbox so who's the real
mvp
all right guys wanted to know
debated stocking stuffers
we still i got two young kids you know
six and eight wanted to know if you know
getting a little surprised in their
stocking in the morning is
an old thing of the past or something
that
uh kids still enjoyed today brandon i
know you got a couple of young kids
theo you look like you probably touch a
couple so
i got this too give me a shout let me
know
peace love y'all you gotta stop them
stuff there's candy man
candy and like little trinkets and [ __ ]
they love it i'll tell you what's
exhausting as a parent
is that elf on a shelf every night you
got to mix it up
get creative with it what the [ __ ] is it
i forgot where i put it he's like where
they at like [ __ ] ct
i don't know where i put them this
morning we found it in a tree outside
yeah we found them in the shower yeah um
i think stocking stuffers is important i
think we used to always have to get our
stock in first like our christmas
tradition
was we have to get our stocking first
get in there hopefully they had some
reese's little uh
peanut butter cups in there but the
little old ones the gold ones yeah
yeah little ones yes sir oh yes
gold red green ones yup yup and then
after that we would do
gifts uh and i don't know if i don't
remember if we did them one at a time
or if we just did them like just royal
rumble style i don't like royal rumble
but i don't either my brother allows
royal rumble at his house dude and it's
just chaos
and then everyone like i like this will
you give that person the attention
it's tough on the person because when it
comes to me it's like oh [ __ ] yeah man
this sweater is cool
you know like you got to act like the
gifts yeah the other thing that uh you
got to think about too when you have
kids
did you did your parents tell you that
was from santa yeah i said
on it i know my girl wants to put sand
i'm like [ __ ] santa you know we dick
jokes a total buy this [ __ ] remote
control card
santa on the thing well it's half or
santa half her dad and mom
dude the little dude has to recognize
that's fine but i think you can't not
have no santa
no we have santa and we're still playing
the santa thing but he's getting savvy
to it because he's like hold on
he's getting savvy because he's watching
damn rick and morty
[Laughter]
rick and morty blows up santa by the way
oh they do yeah they block
dude he's watching and he's watching
probably what else are you guys watching
yeah america's most wanted what else do
you guys watching together yeah
uh dateline verse 48.
what age did you guys believe in santa
until
my kid though at four started asking
some pretty legit questions he's like
hold on santa goes to all the household
yeah you're saying in the entire world
i'm like
yep he goes all the houses he goes well
why wouldn't we just order gifts and
then because
you know amazon he's like why wouldn't
the people from amazon just drop the
gifts off why santa doing all i'm like
dude you're asking too many [ __ ]
questions
yeah legit points sounds like it's got a
future in logistics yeah definitely yeah
sounds like he sounds like you should
handle our merch
sound like you can work for the
bluebirds right there uh
yeah i never believed in santa what was
you always a christmas tradition growing
up chappelle
tradition oh [ __ ] i don't know did you
your white family didn't [ __ ] get lit
on christmas
yeah they always do i just i don't ask
for gifts though i stopped asking for
gifts no one asked for gifts they just
give them to you or
no yeah i'd say don't give me anything
we found out on the patreon exclusive
cats after dark that chappelle
hates uh christmas he's a scrooge yeah
he can't stand it he turns down invites
from what about your girlfriend oh i
turn down invites
you're gonna come over my house for
christmas and it's lit as [ __ ]
christmas is first of all you ain't
gonna point at me like that you know
what
i don't like your attitude on christmas
dude are you
you're mad at christmas because it's
christmas so there has to be some sort
of issue there growing up with christmas
why you don't like it i mean i just i
just never i just never thought it was
like that
cool of a thing or like that thing what
do you mean i don't know i feel like
it's an imagination type thing more of
like a
i don't know i just like you never get a
tree i guess yeah well yeah
my family does the [ __ ] you agree with
what you get i'm just like where did i
get home
would you get a tree like personally for
your house you know what actually
uh i did make my roommate go get a treat
hell yeah it was because we ain't got no
roommate is your girlfriend let me ask
you guys you ever deep throat some
eggnog
would uh just drink it with wild turkey
yeah yeah that's a lot turned out
yeah relapse but yeah i don't know i
just you know like yeah my family every
year
my family says says the same [ __ ] every
year they go they go uh what do you want
we already
know we go they go we already know the
answer but you're invited
and i say no every time you don't show
up to your family christmas parties
man
yeah you shut up dude you don't like
gingerbread cookies
[ __ ] them gingerbread cookies no i don't
really like you man
grinch you would make the best santa you
would make the best santa i've been
standing before i sent you the video
oh he was [ __ ] walking and saying that's
quite walking dirty
that whole thing you know you want me to
send you this oh no but it just breaks
my heart chappelle that you don't like
santa claus me too
that doesn't mean i'm
yeah you usually just hang out hang
around the house it feels amazing
look at steve
[Laughter]
there's a bluetooth in his ear too yeah
yeah you have a bluetooth huh
yeah why y'all going so hard on me about
christmas i love you do you like your
birthday
uh i don't think i can relax sometime i
did something on my birthday man
i can relate to that though but
christmas i don't like birthdays yeah i
love christmas i
uh oh one new uh new year's eye open for
you at the store that was
that was the last time i did something
on new year's years good weekend yeah
that was fun was that last new year's
year no it was like two years ago
i was there too that was last year yeah
was that last year
that's how long 2020's been no no it was
not last year
two years ago we were both for new
year's
holy [ __ ] we're at the store yeah yeah
that's right that was two freaking years
ago
uh so this was a good appetizer uh send
in your christmas
submissions two weeks is our christmas
episode i think we have
uh i don't know if i want to say it but
a special guest from the east coast
coming in
yeah on our christmas episode can i say
it
go ahead andrew schultz uh who's got a
new netflix special
uh coming out and yeah he's going to be
in the culture corner is going to be
in town uh yeah 17th i think so yes sir
if not he'll guest host but
he's going to be and he's going to be
here yeah yeah so
that'll be fun we'll have a tree in our
new stew that will be unveiled next week
on episode 100 and send in
uh audition videos uh you have to be
local to la or get yourself to la
45 seconds are left less why you should
be in the culture corner
why you have culture do be creative with
it 45 seconds or less
why you should be in the culture all
ethnicities white black black
asian jewish muslims or slims as you
call them slim
ethiopians ideally only send in if
you're serious about getting yourself to
l.a
ethiopia this can't be somebody if you
get you got to be
able to go to the show yeah we ain't
flying in from australia
yeah we flying in from fresno
also thursday uh our boy little brows
shout out
little brows part of the cat's family
his new album drops
on thursday on itunes it's an all-cat
soundtrack
you got the thick boy anthem you have
theos austin aka
browser aka dhamma thick cruz i want to
tell you guys to go get the king and the
sting the album available december 10th
um it's a great album i wish i could do
a rapper promo video
but i'm actually at work right now i'm
doing a promo i have an album coming out
nobody cares they do care they should
care because it's got j hutch
who jay hutch you wouldn't get it
[Laughter]
mike stud jelly roll jack champ jack
havoc don papa bear earl faustina
everyone's on there go check it out king
of the sting the album available
december
10th on all streaming platforms and i'll
leave you with this
hey thank you to theo and thank you to
brennan and everyone else that i forgot
to mention it was helping me to get
through the pandemic was going through
depression and feeling so distant i put
on some cats and i just started jogging
and i just kept going when i felt like
stopping and i was going through it felt
like a bad movie scene
sending a rap to the king in the sting
and the rest was history
go get the album i'm out browser i got
it he's so tall
he's so [ __ ] talented dude album
coming out
he's so [ __ ] smelly love that dude
man
job records you don't [ __ ] with job
records [ __ ] y'all
fluffy good thank you sweet that's it
dog i'll be in palm beach end of the
year bring it in with me
and chappelle and the crew and near palm
beach florida
win palm beach improv december 29th
through january 2nd wow really
holla that's crazy dude i uh
where i'll be i got a um cat i got a um
i i'm doing a live show with uh in
january so just stay tuned for i don't
know the date but probably like the 14th
or 15th or so
also cats merch just dropped we got new
[ __ ] hoodies you can see me
rocking it we got uh long sleeves
short sleeves sweats hats we got all
it's
cats merch.com anything else is fake
[ __ ] cats merch dot com holla
and i did want to say about theo's uh
live show it's a live streaming online
like pay-per-view thing not like
in-person live show so
everybody anybody yeah that was
confusing yeah you'd be able to get it
anywhere around the world
anywhere they have internet you can get
it and uh it's gonna be great we're
doing some sketches for it's gonna be a
lot of fun so it'll be great it's gonna
be a belated christmas town extravaganza
yeah that's it man i appreciate it yeah
yeah
gabby you want to plug anything um [ __ ]
i don't have any [ __ ] coming up i guess
my instagram
follow our instagram
wait say it again g-a-b-b-y l-a-m-b-y no
but say it like say all the letters at
once when you like
[Laughter]
we already have that yeah that spot's
taken we already have that
yeah yeah yeah yeah i got to set lips on
me as well
yeah you do i got a set of lips on me
you do
you do yeah you still just look at your
chins yeah they're big
look at china
[Laughter]
why don't you say something you haven't
said anything i said a lot did you yeah
[Music]
i got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
oh yeah king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string
you